[Music]
at all would you mind knowingly toons
all of the reclaims were put inside
really amplify the sound we just want
everyone to have a pleasant dining
experience now who wants a free sample
of beginning I turn it down get our
feed visit unlawful gathering I'm
ordering you to turn down the music and
disperse or we'll be forced I we I
turned it down she okay Silas good I can
do whatever I want now I said turn it
down oh yes makeup oh sweet Jesus sit
down mr. Patric Zakia I take it back and
for the love of Christ
turn that ugly music off
[Music]
oops house not again
Oh God Thank You mr. Popper's crane oh
well guess the riots over I watch be et
you people don't do anything without
music like hell we don't let's take back
our community by destroying it what
should we do
we got the assault throw no you throw I
go lie it's weird without music gimme
and what you think you gonna do with
that mother
[Applause]
[Music]
you
I'm Don Lemon we're here on the ground
in Chamberlain height where events are
quickly spiraling out of control
obviously once again there's a smell of
marijuana in the air and so I'm smoked a
little dosha my your business nigga I've
had a rough day some people would say
that rioting only heard communities that
are already suffering might it not be
more effective to express your
discontent through the ballot box
hey everybody knows that'll make no
difference in the hood only one box max
um what's that brother
hotbox middle that tastes like the
chronic yeah it's a Dijon now that's
what I call a lemon pork
[Applause]
[Music]
what hereis loads in will play this type
of new piano right
[Applause]
like the beard dear white bus been
gentrified the right it reminds me of
Burning Man but before it got all
corporate it looked like we're too late
my me really feels like what's happening
to old neighborhood I'm over this place
yeah our work here is done
hey there's a new neighborhood popping
up and it's real shitty sounds great
let's go give me a short peak
[Music]